speaking now on the Democratic side but
still talking about Maga there are a
hell of a lot of magalunatics that
really like Bobby Kennedy Jr Trump
advisors past and present respect and
celebrate and Revere Robert F Kennedy Jr
saying he's a patriot he's doing a great
service to our country he's bringing up
important issues related to vaccines and
other things I'm going to play clip for
you we will talk about whether it's a
fallacy to do guilt by association you
all know My Views about Bobby Kennedy Jr
some in the audience say I'm too soft on
him some in the audience say I'm too
hard on him I just call it like it is my
friends but let's listen to what Roger
Stone and Michael Flynn and Trump's
lawyer Alina Haba and others have to say
about Bobby Kennedy Jr and then let's
really ask ourselves the most important
question
why do they say these things about Bobby
Kennedy Jr let's listen let's think so
I'm a great admirer of Robert Kennedy
he's a friend of mine I am a fan of
Bobby Kennedy so I want people to know
that I I actually look at him and I
think he's one of those like
um I I think I have a lot in common with
him because I'm a former Democrat I just
changed my party affiliation two years
ago if I were a Democrat I'd certainly
vote for him if I had any money I'd send
him a contribution but I don't I think
RFK Jr is doing a great service to our
country I I am disappointed that his
party is so corrupted I mean he's the
perfect example of a true American
Democrat a two a true patriot who loves
this country I think he is potentially
an extraordinarily uh attractive
candidate at the end of the day however
I believe this is candidacy may serve
the purpose of softening Joe Biden or
Who ah whoever the Democratic nominee is
uh for the candidacy and defeat by the
man who will clearly be no matter what
the courts do the Republican nominee for
president Donald J Trump I think it will
help in the end uh soften Joe bidener or
his defeat by Donald Trump in the
general election he actually has a lot
of a lot of views that are actually uh I
think I think very beneficial across the
board I'm excited that he I mean he's
he's shining the light inside the
Democrat Party
Robert F Kennedy Junior's campaign is
getting traction for one reason he's
speaking truth to power so those are all
deplorable individuals and then of
course I played this very short clip for
you last week Trump also singing the
Praises of Bobby Kennedy Jr then we'll
talk about what this all means
[Music]
a lot of people respect him he's got
some
some very important points to be made no
he's a respected person so listen there
are two elements to this there are two
really important things to this first of
all
this you know when Bobby Kennedy Jr was
asked recently about Trump supports you
what do you think and he says no I'm
proud of that I think that's great
because we're Reaching Across the aisle
or whatever
the reality is
that when really deplorable people like
what you're doing it should immediately
make you ask a two-part question one Are
My Views also deplorable do does the
deplorable person like what I say
because what I say is deplorable or
does the deplorable person like what I
say or claim to like it because I'm
useful to them in some way and with
Bobby Kennedy Jr the answer sadly in a
sense is both okay now let's talk a
little bit about logical fallacies I did
this last week I understand that
strictly speaking guilt by association
is a logical fallacy saying Bobby
Kennedy Jr is bad because Trump likes
him that is guilt by association and
strictly speaking it is a logical
fallacy however we have to be able to
distinguish when guilt by association
should lead us down a path of
Investigation or not if I were to say
and I gave these examples last week
Hitler breathed oxygen so oxygen is bad
that doesn't make any sense you'd say
David sir we need oxygen please if I
were to say Hitler had a doctor who
drugged him up with every drug in the
world and was just a clown so therefore
doctors in general can't be trusted
that's silly wouldn't make any sense but
if I were to say Hitler like Mussolini
and Franco in Italy and Spain so that
should make me skeptical of Mussolini
and Franco that makes sense however I
should still investigate it and I should
say am I right to be skeptical about
Mussolini and Franco I would research
and I would go yes I am we have looked
into every aspect of Bobby Kennedy
Junior's platform or candidacy or
whatever and of course extraordinarily
concerning views about vaccines and
autism foreign policy weird statements
about Russia and China weird uh China's
ethnic racist bio weapon or whatever
statements about the 2020 election the
health policy Roundtable with absolute
medical lunatics on and on and on and
when it comes to Bobby Kennedy Jr these
folks like him for two different reasons
number one
he shares some of their views when it
comes to things like vaccines and Russia
Ukraine to a degree
Etc so in a sense there is an allegiance
or a similarity when it comes to
political positions but in addition to
that and this is really important to
understand
Steve Bannon has been talking up Bobby
Kennedy Jr and his conspiracy theories
for a while Steve Bannon isn't stupid
and Steve Bannon sees Bobby Kennedy Jr
as an agent of chaos he can generate
chaos he can generate chaos by
potentially being a stumbling block for
Joe Biden on the path to his
renomination he could be a stumbling
block for media that might not be
interested in a contested Democratic
primary or whatever the case may be this
is a huge part of why these folks are
now saying Bobby Kennedy Jr it's
absolutely great stuff
so the more we understand about what's
going on the more concerned it should
make us but not just because these
people like Bobby Kennedy Jr but because
of the positions he holds on many issues
as I've outlined to you over the last
several weeks